rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message make decisions that energize you
over to you Mel Robbins I believe that
passion is another word for energy
that's it
what do you have energy for what
energizes you and that we naturally have
a tremendous amount of body wisdom about
that and that every one of us has an
internal fuel tank that is either empty
or full and if you're empty you feel
depleted if you're full you feel
energized and so if you simply are in
any situation I mean any situation and
you pay attention within five seconds to
does this person energize me do they
deplete me where are they in the scale
you just gain some tremendous wisdom and
you the simple way to start to figure
out who you are and what you want is
start aligning yourself with more things
that energize you so situationally if
you're lying in bed and the snooze alarm
goes or the alarm goes off and you feel
depleted and you start reaching for the
snooze button that's a really big sign
that you need to get out of bed now
being depleted versus energized has
nothing to do with whether or not things
are hard or easy it has to do with what
naturally actually either expands you or
shrinks you and so if you look at your
client list and measure it depleted
versus energized what shrinks versus
expands me you have
the actual map and when you start to
find the courage to make decisions that
energize you and that expand you whether
they're scary or not that's when
everything changes and so that's how I
actually make business decisions is this
I don't even like the money conversation
comes second it's does this deplete or
energize me and if it depletes me how do
you move it in that direction or how do
I stay sane oh if it energizes me how do
I do more you are energized or expanded
by something you will do it for no money
you will do it happily and you will
suddenly wake up and say oh my gosh like
my heart I'm pursuing my passion
whatever they love about this message is
that when you are doing work that you
love it brings you energy and it doesn't
take away and think about it you're
doing work most people have this
aversion to work most people think work
is something that is negative that takes
your energy up and then you need a break
from it to do something else to rest or
relax and then come back to it because
it's then going to deplete your energy
again and you have to do other things to
fill your energy where when you find the
thing that you love doing it brings you
energy when I am out meeting
entrepreneurs I'm usually the last one
there because I just outlast everybody
because I just love talking to
entrepreneurs so much and I really care
about them and I really want to help
them that I'm still there and I forget
to eat and forget to go to the bathroom
just because I'm so into what I'm doing
right now I gain energy as the night
goes on I'm making these videos for you
guys today I'm filming 25 major videos
and a bunch of minor ones too I am 18
through my 25 this one right now and I
have more energy than when I started as
I keep going throughout the day I build
up more energy because I love doing this
work and so when you find the thing that
gives you energy then you don't need to
take a break from it all the time you
don't need to get up every half an hour
and take a ten-minute break because what
you're doing is so insanely complicated
like you want to be there for six hours
doing this one thing because time is
flying by that's what you need to find
what I also love about the message
though is yes it applies on a big scale
in terms of finding your passion finding
your life's work finding the thing that
you want to commit and go all-in on for
the next X number of years but it also
applies in the micro it also applies to
every single miniature decision that you
make if you are working at some job and
you hate it and you are just angry about
being there right now or you're just in
a situation that you're not happy with
at the moment you can just ask yourself
that question what can I do right now
that will energize me and it may not
apply to your bigger goals or your big
mission but you can do something
immediately to help give you a little
bit more energy whether that is trying
to figure out your big goals whether
that's to stop and watch a video whether
that's go and do meditation session
whether that's take a walk whether
that's have a shower whether that's do a
brainstorming session
whenever you're feeling low energy
whatever you're feeling negative
whenever you're feeling unhappy
ungrateful but life is beating you down
you can always ask yourself in the
moment what can I do right now that will
give me more energy and that's a really
powerful question ask that most people
don't do they just stay stuck in that
negativity and so the question today
today is I'm curious whether you are
happy right now or depressed or angry or
super pumped what is one thing that you
could do right now to give yourself even
more energy leave it down in the
comments below I'm really excited to see
what you have to say thank you guys as
well for watching I believe in you I
hope we'll continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
let's pray so give me go
do not make any decisions based on money
none it's the worst way to make a
decision which I know is so hard to say
I mean I didn't grow up with any money
and I know so many of us are our
families have a lot at stake they put a
lot into us made a lot of sacrifices for
us and you say you don't have the luxury
of doing that but I actually think you
do you will be more successful if you
make decisions based upon what is going
to feed your soul make you feel value
valued validated you know have you
waking up in the morning and wasting to
work whatever it might be
and I can tell you after a short amount
of time money will not be enough at the
end of the day a bigger paycheck is
another suit or more real estate more
square footage that's what it comes down
to you end up with another room and a
fuller closet and after a while that's
not going to do it the only decisions I
never regretted were ones I made for
impure reasons like to do a movie
because I thought it'd be a big movie or
you know like it'd be popular or
something instead of just really feeling
like it was the right thing to do
creatively so I just think every
decision you guys make should just be
completely from your heart and if you
wouldn't go if you you should only make
stuff you would want to show the whole
world forever
you know and constantly just go from
your heart and don't have anything else
cloud your your judgment
you know purity I know it sounds like
really like straightforward and like
cliche but purity in your decisions just
you're they should come from what you
feel all the time you know personally I
always try to listen because I might be
not and maybe I'm not getting something
I always try and take everybody's
because it's important to listen to
everyone as many people as you can and
get their input but then finally you
have to make your own decision about
what you're gonna do and that's it
that's what you feel and that's it and
that that's the most important thing
I think the most important thing because
that's where the uniqueness comes in
because it's you you've done it it's
your thing it's not anybody else's it's
your choice if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details